♪
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP AT
THE UNITED NATIONS TODAY
WHERE HIS AMERICA FIRST
AGENDA IS CREATING STARK
DIFFERENCES WITH WORLD
LEADERS.
HE HAS ALREADY BUTTED HEADS
ON CLIMATE CHANGE, NORTH
KOREA AND IRAN IT.
ALL COMES BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT'S BIG SPEECH
TOMORROW BEFORE THE GENERAL
ASSEMBLY.
THAT'S HAPPENING AROUND
10:15 TOMORROW.
I WILL BE ON WITH MARTHA
AND -- I KNOW YOU CANNOT
WAIT FOR THAT DO YOU ENJOY
SEEING THE PRESIDENT UP
THERE WITH THE WORLD
LEADERS.
>> Jesse: I LOVE IT.
MUCH BETTER THAN WATCHING
BARACK OBAMA UP THERE AT THE
SAME TIME.
IT COMES DOWN TO WE HAVE OUR
BOYS.
WE HAVE THE BRITISH AND
AUSTRALIANS AND CANADIANS.
>> Dana: DON'T FORGET
MICRONESIA.
>> Greg: MY SOUL COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: NOT SURE WHY WE
HAVE MIKE DEGREE NEARBY
MIVE MIKE DEGREE NEARBY
MICR MIKE DEGREE NEARBY
MICRONIKE DEGREE NEARBY
MICRONESE DEGREE NEARBY
MICRONESIADEGREE NEARBY
MICRONESIA.EGREE NEARBY
THEY ARE ALWAYS SITTING
THERE WITH THEIR HAND OUT.
WE GIVE THEM BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
ONCE WE CUT THE CHECK WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THE MONEY
IS GOING.
THEY ALWAYS VOTE AGAINST US.
BUFF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY?
THEY ARE VOTING THEIR OWN
INTERESTS.
PEOPLE VOTING THEIR OWN
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
I DON'T WANT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES POPULAR
AT THE U.N.
IF HE IS POPULAR AT THE
U.N., HE IS NOT PUTTING
AMERICA FIRST.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THE U.N., AND ALL THESE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTRIES, THEY
TRY TO CONSTRAIN AMERICA,
OUR ENERGY, OUR MILITARY,
ANY TIME WE ARE TRYING TO
ROOT OUT CORRUPTION OR CALL
THEM OUT FOR THEIR, YOU
KNOW, IMMORAL CONDUCT,
THAT'S FINE THE FACT IS THEY
HAVE A HISTORY OF RAPING,
PILLAGING AND SQUANDERING
MONEY AND BLOCKING
DEMOCRATIC PROGRESS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
SO I DON'T LIKE BEING
LECTURED BY THEM AND I'M
SURE THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T
LIKE BEING LECTURED BY THEM,
EITHER.
DO YOU THINK THE CHINESE
CARE WHAT THE U.N. THINKS
THE RUSSIANS CARE?
NO ONE CARES.
WE USE THEM WHEN WE NEED
THEM AND THEN WHEN WE DON'T
NEED THEM WE DO WHAT WE
WANT.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
AGREE WITH, THIS I WAS
THINKING ABOUT IT BEFORE THE
SHOW, THE U.N., YOU HEAR A
LOT MORE ABOUT THEM AND
REALLY, YOU KIND OF HAVEN'T
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF THEY ARE
OFF ON THEIR OWN DOING
SOMETHING NOBODY KNOWS
ABOUT.
>> Juan: NO, OBVIOUSLY THE
UNITED STATES HAS HAD MAJOR
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF THE
SECURITY COUNCIL AND KIND OF
VOTES THAT HAVE TAKEN PLACE.
STARK DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
U.S. POLICY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY ARE
ANTI-SEMITIC AS MY FRIEND
SAID.
>> Jesse: I THINK THERE IS A
RECORD OF ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> Juan: I THINK ARABS ARE
SEMITE.
>> Jesse: ANTI-ISRAELI.
>> Juan: ESPECIALLY CLEAR
WITH TRUMP IN THE WHITE
HOUSE U.N. DOESN'T SET U.S.
FOREIGN POLICY.
THE BETTER ARGUMENT I WOULD
MAKE SORT OF CONTRARY WHAT
WE JUST HEARD FROM JESSE IS
THAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS AIL
I DIDN'T KNOW NATEED SO
ALDIDN'T KNOW NATEED SO
ALIEDN'T KNOW NATEED SO
ALIENA'T KNOW NATEED SO
ALIENATE KNOW NATEED SO
ALIENATEDKNOW NATEED SO
ALIENATED SOW NATEED SO
ALIENATED SO MNATEED SO
ALIENATED SO MANTEED SO
ALIENATED SO MANYEED SO
ALIENATED SO MANY OD SO
ALIENATED SO MANY OF SO
ALIENATED SO MANY OF OO
ALIENATED SO MANY OF OUR
ALLIES.
THEN YOU COME DOWN TO HIS
FOREIGN POLICY.
DIDN'T WE JUST SEND TROOPS
TO SAUDI ARABIA.
WE PULL OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL
IT.
SEEMS TO DESTABILIZE THE
REGION, HAD REPERCUSSIONS HE
DIDN'T ANTICIPATE.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN NORTH KOREA.
THEY ARE TESTING MORE
MISSILES.
YOU STOP AND YOU THINK ABOUT
THE AFGHAN PULLOUT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
I THINK WE ARE STILL IN
AFGHANISTAN.
SYRIA IS ON FIRE.
THAT'S OUR FOREIGN POLICY.
THAT'S NOT THE UNITED
NATIONS.
>> Dana: OKAY.
>> Greg: THAT'S CALLED A
LAUNDRY LIST WAY YOU HAVE
ARGUING.
EACH ONE ALONE DOESN'T MEAN
ANYTHING.
PUT THEM TOGETHER IT MEANS
ZERO.
>> Juan: OUR FOREIGN POLICY
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: EACH ONE OF THOSE
TAKE THEM APART NORTH KOREA
SMALL MISSILES THEY ARE
TESTING.
THE ANALOGY I WOULD USE IS
THAT THE U.N. IS LIKE THE
COLLEGE UNDERGRADS AND THEY
EXPECT THE DEAN, THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES TO APPEASE AND LISTEN
TO THEIR COMPLAINTS AND SAY
WE WILL DO THE BEST WE CAN.
HE IS NOT GOING TO DO THAT
RIGHT?
HE IS NOT GOING TO SIT THERE
AND GO OH WE UNDERSTAND HERE
TAKE MORE MONEY EVEN THOUGH
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST WOMEN
AND GUYS AND JEWS.
THEY DEMAND MONEY FROM
AMERICA AND TRUMP ISN'T
GIVING INTO THEM.
SPEAK TO WHETHER OR NOT HE
IS ALIENATING ANYBODY.
WHENEVER I SEE HIM AROUND
WORLD LEADERS THEY EITHER
WANT TO MEET HIM OR BE HIM.
>> Dana: TALK BADLY BEHIND
HIS BACK THEY ACTUALLY IS
PRETTY SUPPORTIVE.
NEXT ON THIS LIST OF
SUPPORT, CANADA, AUSTRALIA,
GREAT BRITAIN, FRANCE, THAT
SOUNDS.
>> Greg: MICRONESIA.
>> Dana: DON'T FORGET THE
CZECH REPUBLIC.
>> Emily: THE LEFT MAKES A
BIG DEAL ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
BEING AT ODD WITH THE U.N.
LEADERSHIP.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
WORLD DOESN'T SEE THEM AS
THIS GLOWING INTERNATIONAL
BODY.
THEY ARE NOT THE PHYSICAL
CHANGE MAKER FRANKLY THAT
THEY WERE EITHER SUPPOSED TO
BE OR THAT THEY THINK
THEY'RE.
THE PARIS CLIMATE ACCORD WAS
SYMBOLIC.
THEY FILED HOLD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE LOST OUT AND THERE WAS
INCREMENTAL EFFECT ON THE
CLIMATE.
THEY REFUSE TO CONDEMN HAMAS
AND TO RESPONDENT TO YOUR
REQUEST FOR STATISTICS FOR
ANTI-SEMITISM.
LAST YEAR THE U.N. PASSED 21
RESOLUTIONS CONDEMNING
ISRAEL AND ONLY SIX FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
THEY ADOPTED NINE
RESOLUTIONS AGAINST ISRAEL
AND TOTALLY IGNORED SAUDI
ARABIA, VENEZUELA, CHINA,
TUCKERY, PAKISTAN, ET
CETERA, ON AND ON.
I THINK WE SHOULD EMPHASIZE
AS WELL THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT THIS WEEK IS
MEETING BILATERALLY WITH SO
MANY LEADERS, PAKISTAN,
INDIA, EGYPT, JAPAN, ETSZ,
WHICH, TO ME, IS SO MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
ON THE INTERNATIONAL
DIPLOMACY FRONT.